mais ramener brahimi et directeur de
l'observatoire international de
l'aéronautique et de l'aviation civile
de l'école des sciences de la gestion de
l'uqam ont le joint à irvine en
californie
bonsoir monsieur est banni oui bonjour
selon vous est ce que bombardier va
vendre les avions d'affaires doit vendre
ou devrait plutôt garder à tout prix les
avions d'affaires
je pense que bombardier si j'étais à la
place des dirigeants de bombardier
j'y vais sur tous les fronts et de voir
en me départissant de quel divisant et
quel montant d'argent je vais le
chercher
probablement à l'heure actuelle le
regardant du poids de l'état de la santé
et la rentabilité de la division de
l'aviation d'affaires
c'est là où bombardier a plus de marge
de manoeuvre
négocier et d'aller chercher un meilleur
prix et donc parce que j'ai un
portefeuille d'appareils très
intéressant dans la fine pointe des
technologies avec nos vols 5000 mais
aussi avec des challengers et donc une
rentabilité une entreprise qui a été
restructurée récemment très line donc je
dirais très attrayant pour les vendeurs
on en est là aujourd'hui mais en même
temps c'est comme si le canadien il
changeait son meilleur joueur fait quoi
l'avenir de bombardier sein les avions
d'affaires
alors je pense que l'avenir de bombarder
sans l'aviation d'affaires ce sera
probablement et je ne sais pas dans
quelle mesure dans quel état dans le
ferroviaire ou connaissant les déboires
même si aujourd'hui le carnet de
commandes ferroviaires et comme assez
garni à 30 milliards de dollars dans le
ferroviaire
mais pour marquer symboliquement pour
nous au québec au canada s'est associé à
l'aviation puis tous ces exploits donc
dans l'aviation donc je je je vois
l'avenir j'ai déjà sombre d'une certaine
manière si l'aviation ne fait plus
partie du portefeuille d activités de
bombardier
d'autant que là le gouvernement du
québec dit clairement on ne va pas
mettre un sou de plus dans la 220 et
cseries et me suis fatigué benz est
clairement que bombardier va sortir de
là 220 est ce que c'est la bonne voie
écoutez moi je pense que c'est une très
mauvaise voie pourquoi parce que
c'est vrai que dans la transaction de
bombardier du gouvernement du québec et
airbus airbus s'est installé ici à
mirabel et ça c'était une bénédiction
parce que non seulement ça n'a pas créé
un vite mais on a quand même une espèce
cette dynamique industrielle russe avec
son savoir-faire avec son réseau c'est
une bonne chose mais il faut regarder un
petit peu des choses au delà de je
dirais ce qu'on peut lire sur les
réseaux sociaux ou des emplois d'une
autre époque
non nous sommes il faut qu'on voit à
long terme donc on aime savoir faire une
expertise au delà des emplois des deux
opérateurs et techniciens
il faut penser à tout cette expertise
qui a abouti à un avion extraordinaire
questionner ou un global 7500 donc ces
éléments là si on veut profiter à long
terme à moyen terme et à long terme
cette expertise l'amour pour le québec
il va falloir qu'on investisse dans ces
technologies nouvelles dans ces
technologies incertaine qui demande
beaucoup de capitaux et quand on regarde
ddd dans les autres compagnies
aéronautiques à travers le monde qui
sont associés à des états économiquement
très puissant et qui sont toujours des
parts importantes dans le militaire
lourd n'a pas on n'a rien de tout ça
donc si on veut avoir un secteur
aéronautique si on veut continuer à
profiter de ces 12 ou 13 milliards de
dollars que l'aéronautique nous rapporte
chaque année il va falloir qu'on
investisse dans l'avenir et pour
investir dans l'année il faut être
patient il faut et je pense que le
projet de airbus gouvernement du québec
est bombardé c'est un exemple qui va en
sorte que avec les déboires de 737 à 220
peut encore être plus donc en vue et
donc il va falloir investir pour essayer
de récolter les fruits d'un d'avenir if
fait pas son nom et ses leurs hôtes au
gouvernement de jouer ce rôle là pour
que les investisseurs sont impatients
avoir des dde retour sur investissement
à long terme bombardier a mené plusieurs
programmes en même temps au fil du temps
a eu beaucoup beaucoup d'ambitions
qu'elle est qu'elle a été l'erreur de
bombardier pour en arriver où on est
aujourd'hui
alors bon c'est facile après coup de
parler d'erreur mais je pense que vous
avez tout à fait raison
ce fut dur de dire que d'aller sur trois
fronts learjet 85
après
tôt milliards de dollars de dépenses on
aller c'est donc avec cseries en même
temps et global 7000 demain on est allé
dans des dépenses colossales et donc ces
dépenses-là ont fragilisé la situation
financière de bombardier et donc il
fallait peut-être à un moment donné tu
as les plus propres évidemment de
consolider d'abandonner sur un seul
avion et c'est probablement c'est ça
qu'on n'a pas fait et qui est à
l'origine de cette fragilisation
financière peut être aussi si on n'avait
pas fait est qu'aujourd'hui mon produit
était en fin de vie et qui ne se voir
départ leur pedro projet aujourd'hui a
bombardé en disant vous n'avez pas assez
investi dans l'innovation et voilà le
résultat
donc c'est ça qui est la particularité
de secteur aéronautique
c'est à dire que ça nécessite énormément
de capitaux c'est le site énormément de
technologie incertaine qui donnent pas
les résultats au moment tout ce qu'on
veut et c'est pour ça que ça nécessite
que tous les états interviennent et
supportent ces deux secteurs a évolué de
façon très intense
le penny gérer bellemare le pdg alain
bellemare doit-il partir
écoutez je pense que avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour monsieur bellemare
je pense que le problème c'est comme
monsieur bellemare
on revient en train de se [ __ ] que
c'est un bon français sur la roma en
train d'oublier la forêt je pense que
monsieur bellemare est arrivé dans une
chasse aux problématiques la dette était
déjà là un certain nombre de délais des
mauvais choix était déjà là mais
aujourd'hui la question ce n'est pas le
départ de monsieur bellemare c'est que
sur monsieur del monsieur bellemare part
demain les problèmes demeurent et même
si monsieur bellemare n'était pas arrivé
à la tête de bombarder les problèmes
étaient déjà là il faut qu'on pense à
une stratégie nationale pour voir qu'est
ce qu'on veut finalement avec
l'aéronautique et c'est à travers ça qui
va falloir placer un peu comme des
dirigeants de regarder les dirigeants de
l'espagne et la france et est là et
l'allemagne font à chaque fois qu'on
veut nommer un président à la tête
d'airbus la question au-delà de cette
politique là au delà des individus
cédait 2 d'assurer l'intérêt général qui
est dans un renforcement du secteur
aéronautique par le biais des airbus non
cette espèce de maturité sagesse
politique et économique en disant c'est
pas belles marques et le problème c'est
qu est-ce qu comment on va avoir une
place
temps là dans l'aéronautique de jemal
monsieur ebrahimi très intéressant
passionnante analyse merci c'est
toujours un plaisir au studio donc j'en
ai trois besson